[Music]
what in relation to the single
individual appears as his culture as the
essential moment of the substance itself
that is the immediate passage of the
mere thought form of its universality
into actuality or culture is the simple
soul of the substance by means of which
what is implicit in the substance
acquires an acknowledged real existence
the process in which the individuality
molds itself by culture is therefore at
the same time the development of it has
the universal objective essence that is
the development of the actual world
although this world is come into being
through individuality it is for self
consciousness immediately an alienated
world which has the form of a fixed and
solid reality over against but at the
same time certain that this world is its
substance it sets about making it its
own it gains this power over it through
culture which looked at it from this
aspect he has the appearance of self
consciousness making itself conform to
reality and doing so to the extent of
the energy of its original character and
talent permits what appears here is the
power and authority of the individual
exercised over the substance which is
thereby superseded is the same thing as
the actualization of the substance for
the power of the individual consists in
conforming itself to that substance that
is in externalizing its own self and
thus establishing itself as substance
that has an objective existence its
culture in its own actuality are
therefore the actualization of the
substance itself
now in paragraph 490 we're starting to
get moving into the the main dialectic
that that is occurring here in this
entire discussion of culture or in
German build on a process of development
of the the self and it's in relation to
alienation which which is not really
that important in this paragraph but
which will be in the in the next
paragraph and the paragraphs following
that notice that Hegel here is going to
be talking in terms of a movement not
only of the individual and the world in
relation to each other but particularly
in terms of substance so there's really
kind of two things going on here there's
the relationship of the individual to
the world and then there's this totality
of substance which is spirit spirit now
alienated from itself in this section so
Hegel begins this by saying what in
relation to the single individual the
Ines of the individual appears as his
culture is the essential the Bazin lika
moment of the substance itself what is
the substance itself we are back now
considering what we had been talking
about in in the end of the reason
section and also throughout this spirit
section as ethical substance but now
it's an ethical substance that is is by
its very nature alienated from itself
and there's going to be a kind of
process of recuperation and this is
going to run the course of this entire
long subsection of spirit so he says
what is this this essential moment of
the substance itself the immediate
passage of the mere thought form of its
universality into actuality or he says
culture is the simple soul of the
substance by means of which what is
implicit in the substance acquires an
acknowledged real existence this is very
important this
this discussion here Hegel is noting two
different things going on that are
really running parallel to each other
and are two ways of looking at the same
thing so on the one hand I have here on
the board the movement from the the form
and thought of actuality the idea to of
universality rather to actuality that is
occurring through through culture
through enculturation through formation
now it's happening in terms of
individuals right but individuals
comprise you know the you might say the
fabric the matrix of an entire society
an entire world at the same time as you
said this is a passage from
implicitness what is merely implicit in
the thought to something else and and
what's that something else is not just
something existing but here he uses that
that term that Miller is translating as
acknowledged right acknowledged here is
a it's a cognate of that honor cannon
that we saw that self-consciousness has
been looking for and trying to attain
this entire time so what is happening in
these these sections on alienated spirit
finding itself in culture is a new level
of on-air Kennan of recognition or
acknowledgement very important that we
follow this out he goes on and he says
the process in which the individuality
molds itself by culture is therefore at
the same time the development of it as
the universal objective essence so we
can draw a parallel here between the
individual and the universality a
universality that is not becoming you
know something different than
universality in becoming actuality it's
becoming a real universal and the
individual is doing so through culture
now you might say how can an end
you'll become the universal maybe you
have in mind
something like you know what we've
talked about as world historical
individuals we just passed earlier
through talking about the Lord of the
world as the the real meaning of the the
world of legal right but we saw that
that was kind of empty we saw that as we
opened up that form of ethical substance
it turned out to be arbitrary capricious
can we get to something that isn't so
that's the what what culture is offering
to us something more something
determinate something that remains a
universal that is something we can
cognize and understand and relate
ourselves to and even find ourselves in
so he goes on and he says this process
right the individuality molds itself by
culture it's the development of the
actual world now isn't that an
interesting thing to say haven't we had
the world here all of this time well yes
we have and we've seen many different
ways in which the world can be
understood now we're seeing another way
in which the world presents itself to us
in which the individual or rather we
must think of this in plural right
individuals are building an actual world
in which they might be able to be
recognized and recognize each other in
which they can in fact be spirit or at
least parts or moments of spirit in
relation to others going from what
what's merely implicit to making it
explicit making it exist making it real
going on he says this world has come
into being through individuality but now
notice it is for self consciousness an
alienated world
which has the form of a fixed and solid
reality over against it now this is in
part we can understand because it's not
just me creating that world it's also
other self consciousness is creating
that world but there's also an aspect of
this in which by taking part in that
creation of the world by taking part in
in actual lysing it in making it be a
world and not just a reflection of my
own thoughts something real I lose
something of myself
I am alienated I am estranged from it it
slips beyond my grasp we've seen this
before in how it is that action works
right back in the reason section now
we're seeing it again here in spirit
section in terms of this process of
formation of self and there's there's a
dialectic here and I'm using this term
dialectic in its broadest sense in which
we can talk about a back and forth and a
you know two sides almost speaking to
each other on the one hand the
individual by you know building or
forming him or herself is developing
further right on the other hand they're
not doing so in a vacuum that culture is
something that does not come directly
from them alone they're inheriting it
they are finding it within their their
history or their their framework or
their society and they're taking it on
and conforming themselves to it so this
is this is a process in which the the
culture itself is being enriched by the
contribution of the individual making it
actual but it's also one in which the
individual is losing something of him or
herself in the process
losing him or herself in order to become
something different so
we have individual and world hey GU
Roseanne Tony says at the same time
certain that this world is its substance
it sets about making it its own here's
the positive part of the inculturation
it gains this power over it through
culture and then he says looked at from
this aspect what is culture it it has
the appearance of self consciousness
making it conform to reality you
encounter the the culture in the sense
not of what you're doing to yourself yet
but in terms of a positivity that that
presents itself to you you are you know
for example in my case a man born into a
certain time where there are notions
about what men and women and boys
developing into men and girls developing
into women do right or we can talk in
terms of class or we can talk in terms
of you know geographical location or we
can talk in terms of all these different
things that comprise culture these
differentiations and by by listening to
the the culture that that tells me where
I fit in I am not completely developed
at this point but I get the the notes
that tell me okay you go down this path
and do these things to yourself or have
them done to you you know a good example
of this that was discussed recently
which you know I I'm actually quoting it
quite an agreement with when it comes to
say gender roles is for a long time you
know as it's been said for boys be a man
don't you ever cry don't show fear anger
is okay right and what does this do this
gives us individuals who in their
process of development don't learn how
to say express sorrow and understand it
adequately even though if we look back
at our our culture our you know heritage
and we read The Odyssey we would see a
discus weeping and has men weeping
together
in their boat as they row over their
fallen comrades
I remember a book that my father had on
a shelf written by by a football player
and it was called big big guys don't cry
right and it was a very interesting book
because it was about this this issue of
learning titute could condition yourself
so that you're not going to express
sorrow or weakness or those sorts of
things well that is part of culture now
that's only one example there's so many
other possible examples that we could
come up with but they would fit this
dynamic we gain the world back for
ourselves not by saying screw you world
I'm not going to conform to your norms
but by conforming to those norms and
thereby taking the world back so
interestingly individuality turns it out
to be something that you can really only
keep through you might say not
necessarily giving it entirely away but
at least spending part of itself through
this this process of enculturation to
gain something else so he says it makes
itself conform to reality and doing so
to the extent that the energy of the
original character and talent permit we
saw that this is something that the
individual has Hegel is not a huge fan
of a you know original character he
thinks that it's something that has to
be developed right but talent that plays
a role so he says what appears here is
the power and authority of the
individual exercised over the substance
which is hereby superseded alcohol burn
right is the same thing as the
actualization of the substance so we
should say that one more time what
appears of the power and authority of
the individual exercised over this
substance is the same thing as the
actualization of the substance why the
power of the individual consists in
conforming itself to that substance
externalizing its own self thus
establishing itself as substance that
has an objective existence that is
actual that has been made actual in the
world so he goes on and finishes by
saying its culture and its own actuality
are therefore the actualization of
the substance itself what is this
substance itself well think about what
it is to be human
human beings are not the only animal
that has any culture whatsoever but
culture is so important for us we have a
not an infinite but a much greater
plasticity a capacity to be universal
but we do so precisely by as individuals
shedding some of that individuality and
taking on what culture affords us and
thereby making us into not just thoughts
of universality but actualize
universalities that can be in a state of
recognition with each other this is a
very optimistic point of view on culture
so far
the self knows itself as actual only as
transit transcend itself therefore it is
not constituted by the unity of
consciousness of itself and the object
on the contrary the object is for the
self its negative thus by means of the
self is soul of the process substance is
so molded and developed in its moments
that one opposite stirs the other into
life each by its alienation from the
other gives it an existence and equally
receives from it in existence of its own
at the same time each moment possesses
its own specific nature is something
unchallengeable valid and as affirm
reality visa be the other thinking fixes
this difference in the most general way
by the absolute antithesis of good and
bad which shunning each other cannot in
any way become one and the same the soul
of this fixed being however is the
immediate transition into its opposite
existence is really the perversion of
every determinate nests into its
opposite and it is only this alienation
that is the essential nature and support
of the whole we have now to consider
this process in which the moments are
stirred into life and given an existence
of their own the alienation will
alienate itself and the whole will
through this alienation return into its
notion
Hegel is describing a fascinating
movement that is developing here at
least in the beginnings in paragraph 491
where he's gonna introduce an absolute
antithesis of good and bad in terms of
thinking that's gonna play an important
role in the paragraphs yet to come he
begins by talking about the self as a
transcended self there's a lot going on
here and he's going to finish up this
paragraph by talking in terms of
alienation alienating itself so there's
really a lot that that's being said here
at least by way of implication and we're
gonna see this play itself out in as I
said the paragraph yet to come so he
tells us he begins us by telling us that
the self knows itself as actual only as
a transcended self and that's a little
bit of a you know fast and loose
translation of saying that the self
knows itself as alcohol bonus that is
transcending or sub lading however even
translate that veer click actual
actualized right so Hegel is not saying
that at first it knows itself as
transcendent or as actualized and we put
these two together they are actually
together in in that the passage but it's
not bad for Miller to sort of split this
apart because what's going on here is we
have the relation between the self as we
could say we first know it or the self
in terms of its universality right and
then the actual self that that we become
through this process of culture through
education through formation through you
know being given models and and
following them and seeing how they pan
out and there is a kind of transcendence
that that goes on through that it's not
necessarily a transcendence that raises
up
very highest level of everything but
there is a process of in in development
it's a process of continual
self-transcendence that is what a real
education or formation does involve and
there are sometimes break points where
we recognize this by moving somebody
from one rank to another or we recognize
this in ourselves and that's important
now Hegel then is going to talk about
substance again and he's he's framing
this in terms of the self Patil he says
it's not constituted by the unity of
consciousness of itself in the object on
the contrary the object is for the self
it's negative thus by means of the self
as soul of the process substance
substance is so molded and developed
into in its moments that one opposite
stirs the other into life so this is the
the you know typical Hegelian dialectic
right the self same repels the self same
from itself into its other and we're
talking here in terms of consciousnesses
or in terms of determinate individuality
x' or social forces all of these we are
going to play a role here and so he
talks about the substance as as
splitting itself into polarities what do
these look like he doesn't tell us very
much here he says each by its alienation
from the other gives it an existence and
equally receives from an existence of
its own so there is a kind of
reciprocity going on they're not doing
exactly the same thing because if they
did they would just be the same thing
right but we have each of them
contrasting with each other each of them
existing in their tension and here then
Hegel brings up goodness and badness
moral categories right he says at the
same time each moment possesses its own
specific nature as something
unchallengeable Eve Aled and affirm
reality visa view the other so whether
it's black and white you know
we want to use some of Hegel's rather
outmoded physical things you know acid
and base that doesn't really work that
well but or we want to use other
determinations each of them exists by
its opposition to the other but each of
them exists as something as well
now Eagles gonna bring up goodness and
badness boot and schlecht right why why
would Hagel bring that up well we are
dealing inevitably with the moral sphere
or we might say the practical sphere the
sphere in which human beings try to make
of themselves and their lives and their
resources something actual and they do
so in opposition to others or at least
in contrast with others so he goes on
and he says thinking fixes this
difference in the most general way by an
absolute antithesis and and Kagan's
Etzel right setting themselves apart in
terms of good and bad so he says these
tion each other they cannot in any way
become one in the same we've seem to
have something solid that we can work
with now are you gonna be good are you
going to be bad culture of course would
tell you be good right it needs the bad
as something like a contrast but does it
it's it's unclear at this point isn't it
or rather it's over determined on the
one hand no goodness without badness no
badness without goodness on the other
hand each of them existing as positivity
in their own right as solid as stable
that's the way Hegel is depicting it
this is only in the realm of thought
though so he says the soul of this fixed
being is the immediate transition into
its opposite existence is really the
perversion of every determinant 'no sin
to its opposite
is a very general statement existence is
really the perversion of every
determinist into its opposite right
everything can become something else and
he says it's only the alienation that is
the essential nature and support of the
whole now here is where Hegel is going
to become very speculative right and
he's telling us what we're going to be
studying in the paragraphs coming up
since we now I have to consider this
process in which the moments are stirred
into life and given an existence of
their own right how does this in fact
play itself out within the historically
founded dialectic how do individuality
x' in cultures in time in what we've
experienced or what we are you know
others have experienced and we're now
becoming conscious of how did they in
fact purse out this distinction between
good and bad in relation to each other
and the alienation that comes with that
now here's where Hegel ends by saying
something sort of predictive the
alienation will alienate itself and the
whole will through this alienation
returned into its notion its concept
it's the gift what we've been seeking
this entire time
alienation of alienation does that bring
us back to the start
no it brings us to a higher point
transcendence that's what we're about to
enter into with the paragraphs to come
you